[Music]
thank you foreign
welcome back to another episode of what's up Prof
hello Walter this time you beat me to it right I
have to try sometimes to be ahead okay it doesn't
work always let's open with the word of Prayer
start our heavenly father thank you once
again for bringing us together thank you
for having us do these discussions and we
and ask that you Enlighten our minds that
we can do it the way that you would
like us to in Jesus name amen amen
now modern as we said we do not only want to say
where we are standing in the current world events
but we also would like to discuss some of the
spiritual aspects that need to fall into place
so while the world is preparing to introduce
the next wave let's put it that way
we can talk about spiritual things and then
when the next wave comes we can report on the
Pope's letter and on cop 27 27 and all
of these things that are taking place
but while they're giving us a breather let's talk
about spiritual things as well because actually
isn't that what we have to prepare to take on
all of these things yes because we we are not
supposed to only know what's happening in the
world but we need to prepare spiritually for
what is coming upon the world because if we are
not spiritually prepared we will not be able to
stand we need to have the faith of Jesus and the
faith of Jesus was prepared to go to the cross
and Peter at that stage never had the faith of
Jesus you had the faith of Peter yeah and three
times he denied and I was just reading again
last night and I found it again so overwhelming
the first one who asked him are you not one
of them who was the the lady who kept the door
so when he came in yeah at the door very first one
he saw said you're one of them he said no I'm not
then he went and warned warmed himself at the fire
right and he warmed himself and they all of them
said you're one of them and he denied it right now
the third one who asked him do you remember it was
it was inside where Jesus was accused but I
can't remember exactly and and when I read it
it suddenly struck me why do I miss these things
I missed it I I really missed it the the third one
who asked him was the one whose ear had been cut
off wow okay no yeah it's in the Gospel of John
the one whose ear has been cut off I I recognize
you wow and that's why he must have been so
adamant because he knew it was it was the the high
priest servant or whatever and he knew that it cut
off his ears so he had to deny it most vehemently
isn't that interesting but God put those three
people there yes those three groups yeah first a
lady then a group and then the very one who had
being confronted by Peter that's the one and
that was too much for him so Martin we need to
be prepared for what is coming so this one is
titled arise and shine well we're heading for
the crisis of the ages so that's what we need to
prepare for right at least in a spiritual sense
in Joel chapter 2 we read blow ye the trumpet
in Zion and sand and Alam in my Holy Mountain
let all the inhabitants of the land tremble for
the day of the Lord cometh for it is nigh at hand
so this is our job right this is what God's
people have to do troubles times are right upon
us the fulfilling of the signs of the times gives
evidence that the day of the Lord is near at hand
I just went through the news and I saw
all of these events taking place where
Christian nationalism is on the rise and I'm
sure you're Gathering a lot of information
so the listeners must be aware that we are looking
at all of these things but let's wait until we
have a nice package to put together oh well and
then we can see where we're going we uh three I
think three episodes ago we in actual fact did
one on the Christian nationalism yes but the
the momentum that was picking up huh and you have
articles in the guardian and you have articles in
in prominent places where they are talking about
it just on okay now that on that point but it's
um not strange it's actually scary how the
Christian nationalism is also linking to
Civil War yes all of that is coming together and
how the immorality is being legislated more and
more but we're not going there it's we're just
read here the fulfilling of the signs of the
times gives evidence that the day of the Lord
is near at hand just to show that you know this
is really happening the daily papers are full of
indications of a terrible conflict in the future
bold robberies of frequent occurrence strikes
are common we just had a strike in our country
that laid the transport industry lame the shipping
industry was lame nothing can be exported nothing
can be imported the farmers goods are rotting
on in the ship's holds and it's just a calamity
thefts and murders are committed on every hand men
possessed of demons are taking the lives of men
and women and little children all these things
testify that the coming of Christ is near at
hand in accidents and calamities by land and by
sea in great conflagrations in Fierce tornadoes
terrific hailstorm Tempest floods Cyclones
tidal waves earthquakes in every place and
in thousands of forms Satan is exercising his
power the crisis is stealing gradually upon us
the sun shines in the heavens passing over its
usual round and the heavens still declare the
glory of God men are still eating and drinking
planting and building marrying and giving into
marriage Merchants are still buying and selling
pleasure lovers are still crowding to theaters
horse races gambling Hills the highest excitement
prevails yet probation's hour is fast closing
and every case is about to be eternally decided
Satan sees that the time is short he has set all
the agents to work that men may be deceived
deluded occupied entranced until the day of
probation shall be ended and the door of mercy
be forever shut so Martin do we have a work to do
and the time is short all right so
let's continue the time is right upon us
when there will be sorrow that no human bomb can
heal Sentinel angels are now restraining the Four
Winds that they shall not blow till the Servants
of God are sealed in their forests but when God
shall bit the Angels loose the winds there will
be a scene of strife such as no pen can picture
Our God shall come and shall not keep silence
he shall call to the heavens from above and to
the Earth that he may judge his people gather my
Saints together under me those that have made a
covenant with me by sacrifice so Martin this is
the state of the world and this is the time that
we are living in and how much more so now than
when these words were pinned right so much more
so we must be partakers of Christ's suffering
here if we should share in his glory hereafter
if we seek our own interest how we can best
please ourselves instead of seeking to please God
and Advance his precious suffering cause we shall
dishonor God and the Holy cause we profess to love
we have but a little space of time left
in which to work for God nothing should
be too dear to sacrifice for the Salvation
of the scattered and torn flock of Jesus
those who make a covenant with God by sacrifice
now will soon be gathered home to share a rich
reward and possess the New Kingdom forever and
ever oh let us live holy for the Lord and so by a
well-ordered life and godly conversation that we
have been with Jesus and are his meek and lowly
followers we must work while the day lasts for
when the Dark Night of trouble and anguish comes
it will be too late to work for God Jesus is in
his holy Temple and will now accept our sacrifices
our prayers our confessions our faults and sins
and will pardon all the transgressions of Israel
that there may be blotted out before he leaves
the sanctuary when Jesus leaves the sanctuary
then they were holy and righteous will be holy and
righteous still for all their sins will then be
blooded out and they will be sealed with the Seal
of the Living God but those that are unjust and
filthy will be unjust and filthy still for then
there will be no priest in the sanctuary to offer
their sacrifices their confessions their prayers
before the father's throne therefore what is done
to rescue Souls from the coming storm of Wrath
must be done before Jesus leaves the most holy
place of the Heavenly sanctuary Martin I don't
know about you but I feel driven it's as though I
can see the sand of time running out and there
are so many people even within our own family
that are not ready yeah and the time as you say
is depleting so quick that something spiritual
Godly is driving you how do you prepare
Minds that do not want to be prepared
how do you reach people that have closed
the door how do you touch a spiritual cord
how do you do it well we can't cannot but
it's frustrating but that's where God comes in
we are the Sowers he's the husbandman yeah he
must make it grow but Martin it seems as though
the odds are stacked against us definitely it
seems that the enemy is not only working from
without his working from within as well and he's
is very effective when it comes to working within
right we have more to fear from within than from
without that is problematic so Isaiah gives us
our marching orders and this is also where we take
our title from a rise sign for thy light has come
and the glory of the Lord is risen upon thee for
Behold The Darkness shall cover the Earth and
gross Darkness the people but the Lord shall rise
upon thee and His glory shall be seen upon thee
so imagine if you have had great light that
means you have great responsibility right
you can't just say well I've I've got
the light I'm so glad I have the light
what about those that don't have the
light what is that verse that says
you can't hide it under a bushel now
when we were blind we were with excuse
but when he made that little puddle of Mud and put
it on our eyes and sent us to the pool of Siloam
which means scent then you are sent to perform a
a certain Duty you have to go and witness to those
who don't want to hear right yeah so he went to
the Pharisees and they said to him who healed you
and he said it was Jesus but he hadn't seen him
yet but he knew it was and he opened the eyes
and never since the world began has it been that
someone opened the eyes of those that were born
blind if this man was a sinner or not I know not
one thing I do know is I was blind and now I see
this man is the sinner because he did it on the
Sabbath day and you were born in sin they said to
him whether he was a sinner or not I don't know
but I know that I was blind and now I see do you
want to be his disciples too if you ask me again
can you imagine that story so in other words when
you have received light then you are sent and when
you are sent you run up against the brick wall
that hey that's life that's life right and the
Gentiles shall come to thy light and Kings to the
brightness of thy Rising that's quite a promise
lift up thine eyes around about and see all they
gathered themselves together they come to thee
thy son shall come from far and thy daughter
shall be nursed at thy side then Thou shalt see
and flow together in thine heart shall fear and
be enlarged because the abundance of the sea
shall be converted unto thee that's the Nations
the forces of the Gentiles shall come unto
thee the multitude of camels shall cover
thee in the dromedaries of median and ether all
they from Sheba shall come they shall bring gold
and incense and they shall show forth the Praises
of the Lord now what do you make of that promise
when is that going to take place Martin the
latter rain Martin this is the letter reign
can you imagine Martin when they start coming
when the Nations start coming but before they
can come they must have a message in other words
we must give the message a loud cry and then comes
the loud cry and the loud cry is a harvesting call
that's a they must have already heard the message
I mean the the message went out in the time of
Jesus right before the early Reign yeah Jesus
had sown The Good Seed and he had sown the good
seed and the people had watched The Miracles
and the people knew about him that people knew
all of these things but they weren't convicted
they'd heard his Parables they'd
heard his teachings they they
disgusted amongst themselves they
argued about it and some of them
condemned it some of them accepted it
the whole Gambit the truth was out there
but it laid dormant and then under the power of
the early reign they came in by the thousands
is this going to happen at the end yes at the
later rain yes even more even more so yeah
so in other words all these people will come but
they must have something to come to do you think
they are arguing about some of the presentations
that are going into the world today not only from
us but from many many speakers and thinking well
have these people got a point to have they not got
a point are they arguing about these issues yes
have you seen this one have you heard about that
one are these people insane are they nuts are they
this are they that you know did it happen in the
time of Jesus differently so we have to agitate
agitate agitate right well we have opposition
numerous did Jesus have opposition yes
did the disciples have opposition they
were actually all killed all right
that's very very encouraging mark
but this is going to happen this is what must
happen under the latter rain arise and shine
for your light has come must you have light in
order to give light cannot do it any way other
chapter 60 verse 7 all the flocks of kedar shall
be gathered together unto thee the Rams of nabayat
shall Minister unto thee they shall come up with
acceptance on mine Altar and I will glorify the
house of my glory is he talking about sheep and
goats no people he's talking about people who
are these that fly as a cloud and as the doves to
their windows surely the Isles shall wait for me
and the ships of tarshis first to bring thy sons
from afar their silver and their gold with them
unto the name of the Lord thy God and to the Holy
One of Israel because he has glorified thee not
the silver and gold Martin is it literal no isn't
silver character that has been refined in the fire
and gold is Faith and love so these people will
have accepted the gospel and they must be gathered
so they will come from all over the world and the
sons of the strangers shall build up thy walls in
other words they'll defend the Commandments of
God they must have heard about them from someone
and their kings shall Minister unto thee for in
my wrath i smote thee but in my favor I have had
mercy on thee therefore thy Gates shall be opened
continually they shall not be shut day nor night
what does the gates stand for Martin for judgment
that's where the judges used to gather they always
used to gather at the gate and the wall was quite
a thick wall and so the Judiciary was actually
built into the wall at the gate and you went to
the gate for judgment and judgment is based on
the law so the gates of judgment shall be opened
continually to receive these people who's the one
who judges them God God he brings them in the
Holy One of Israel that men may bring unto thee
the forces of the Gentiles and that their kings
may be brought for the nation and the kingdom
that will not serve thee Shall Perish yea those
Nations shall be utterly wasted in other words
what they are saying what Isaiah is saying here
if they do not acknowledge that you have the truth
they will be lost that's it so it's
not that the Kings will come and
serve you they will acknowledge that
you are representing a higher Kingdom
and that they have to obey that Kingdom which
is the kingdom of the Lord so this is the great
promise of what will happen under the latter
rain to an extent also under the former rain
because even people from Caesar's household were
converted yeah and many kings thereafter in the
Reformation were converted and leaders
were converted and in the end there will
be people even in the political Realm that
will acknowledge the truth and come out yeah
so we mustn't write off everyone no no we must
look at some of them and think oh this one has
we'll never make it you see the problem is we've
you've mentioned this many times before yes like
when if you had to judge Aaron yes he would
have been wrongly judging because when he did
the cough yes the golden Cove write him off write
him off yes we mustn't write off anyone we must
just keep on on praying because there were many
kings in Israel that did horrendous things that
were converted in the end so God will give the
wisdom the glory of Lebanon shall come upon thee
the fir tree the pine tree the box together is he
talking about trees no so if you're a righteous
the Bible refers to the the righteous as trees
planted in the fertile Valley or along the streams
to beautify the place of my sanctuary and
I will make the place of my feet glorious
the sons also of them that Afflicted thee shall
come bending unto thee and all they that despise
thee shall bow themselves down at the souls of thy
feet and they shall call Thee the city of the Lord
the Zion of the Holy One of Israel this is a great
promise that many many that were against you will
eventually see the light so you must never lose
hope always have faith that God can change and
save anybody Paul mentions the three faith hope
and love right and the greatest of these is love
love hope will go faith will go love will remain
love will remain forever yeah but faith and hope
will disappear out of the dictionary because once
you have attained you don't have to hope for it
and once you can see it you don't have to have
faith anymore that's always such a a difficult one
to understand where Jesus actually says you know
there are some things that you you wonder why
is it written like this or why did the Lord say
things the way that he did we're speaking about
faith right we're speaking about love we're
speaking about hope and you know if I take my
Bible and if I remember correctly it's in John
I think it's chapter 14. no it's in chapter 16.
16 where Jesus says from verse 8. and when he has
come this is the holy spirit he will reprove the
world of sin and of righteousness and of judgment
right those three and then he he qualifies them
of sin because they believe not on me so
modern is that the sin not to believe Christ
do you have to believe in him definitely that's a
sin right yeah so I am the way the truth and the
life nobody comes to the father except by me he
said so if you do not believe that it's a sin sin
and that means you can't have eternal
life because the wages of sin is death
so it's a strange way of saying it of sin because
they believe not on me and then the next one is
even stranger of righteousness because I
go to the father and you see me no more
faith faith because it's righteousness by faith
right so why must it be by faith because it's not
here and you can't see him anymore therefore
it has to be by faith yeah but faith is the
substance of things hoped for the evidence of
Things Not Seen so it has to be righteousness
by faith so how am I saved through faith and I can
only exercise faith in something that I cannot see
right yes so it's actually a brilliant way of
putting it of righteousness because I go to the
father and you see me no more therefore you have
to accept it by faith and if you don't accept it
by faith you're lost so now what about all these
systems that don't accept righteousness by faith
they have to one of those systems that declare it
in anathema how do they get past verse 10. they're
in big trouble right and then of judgment because
the prince of this world is judged but Martin is a
roaring lion why is he a roaring lion you're right
because he's judged ah I love this Bible it is so
wonderfully put at the the way in which it is said
sometimes makes you stumble and you think why is
it written like that but when you start analyzing
him that's why this must be divinely inspired
and the disciples remembered that word for word
because it's written in red they're quoting Jesus
now he wrote that a long time afterwards
John he was sitting somewhere and writing
well coming to think of it I mentioned
earlier that all the disciples were killed
but there's also the promise of John
yes that went that wasn't killed by them
but was with old age all right but did
they tried to kill him oh numerous times
there's a promise as well in the times that
we're living in and we have to go through
bringing this message to the world all right so
verse 15 says whereas the thou has been Forsaken
and hated so that no man went through Thee I
will make the an eternal Excellency a joy of
many generations Thou shalt also suck the milk
of the Gentiles and thou shalt suck the breast
of the Kings and thou shalt know that I the Lord
and thy Savior and thy Redeemer the mighty one of
Jacob in other words the Gentiles and the Kings
will come to your Aid and help to nourish you
cure they will supply the means that are
necessary for whatever has to be done
for brass I will bring gold for iron I will
bring silver and for wood brass so is there an
upgrading yes for Stones iron I will also make thy
officers peace and thine exact as righteousness
violence shall no more be heard in thy land
wasting no destruction within thy borders but
Thou shalt call thy world salvation and
thy Gates Praise In other words the law
and the judgments you will praise them righteous
are thy judgments so in other words all these
people that have heard the message will be
convicted under the outpouring of the latter
rain and the loud cry and many many will turn
to God they will come out of Babylon in droves
and sadly many in God's Church will
leave but their numbers will not decline
the sun shall be no more thy light by day
neither for brightness shall the moon give
light unto thee but the Lord shall be unto thee
and everlasting light and thy God thy glory in
other words in that Celestial City it out shines
the sun one to ten so you don't need it right
the sun shall no more go down neither shall the
moon with joy itself for the Lord shall be thine
Everlasting Light in the day of thy mourning
shall be ended that's the promise of eternal
life the people also shall be all righteousness
they shall inherit the land forever the branch
of my planting the work of my hands that I
may be glorified a little one shall become
a thousand and a small one a strong Nation I the
Lord will hasten it in his time so these are the
promises that we have for the outpouring of the
latter rain and for the restoration of all things
so how important is it that we let our light shine
now there's no other time because we are in Gross
Darkness work while the day last exactly okay so
what you are saying is that we've got the period
before the second coming where the letter rain
is falling and then after that the period that
we are in heaven yeah when everything is restored
and what it will be like there absolutely correct
all right so let's look at the these typologies
because we're talking about a rise and shine so
we need to know what is it that we must do
because all of these people must accept the
truth otherwise they can't come to you in droves
yeah so the sewing must have been done exactly
and under the latter rain they must be called in
let's have a look at this story in First Kings
chapter 9 onwards and it came to pass when Solomon
had finished the building of the house of the Lord
and the King's house and all Solomon's desire
which he was pleased to do now Solomon was
building a physical house the temple we
are instructed to build a spiritual house
ye are the Temple of the living Gods is Paul
so the church we have to build up the church
and it consists of Living Stones
so let's get the parallels here
that the Lord appeared to Solomon the second
time as he had appeared unto him at gibeon
and the Lord said unto him I have heard thy
prayer and thy supplication that those made
before me I have hallowed this house which thou
Hast built to put my name there forever what is
that entail his character and my eyes and my heart
shall be there perpetually and if conditional
they would walk before me as David thy father
walked in Integrity of heart and in uprightness
to do according to all that I have commanded thee
and will keep my statutes and my judgments then
is their condition definitely does it still apply
and it's not only mentioned here it is mentioned
numerous times so obviously it still applies
today then I will establish the Throne of thy
kingdom upon Israel forever as I promised to David
thy father saying there shall not fail the a man
upon the throne of Israel was he talking about
Solomon or was he talking about Christ Christ
but conditional yep if you don't if you shall at
all turn from following me ye or your children
and will not keep my Commandments and my statutes
which I've said before you but go and serve other
gods to worship them and then comes a result right
does the same apply for the spiritual house yes
definitely why don't people get that no because
they don't want it to pertain to themselves as
well then while I cut off Israel out of the land
which I have given them in this house which I have
hallowed for my name will I cast out of my sight
and Israel shall be a proverb and a byword amongst
all the people did it happen to the literal Temple
yes can it happen to a spiritual Temple definitely
and at this house which is high everyone that
passes by shall be astonished and shall hiss
and they shall say why has the Lord done
thus unto this land and unto this house
and they shall answer because they forsook
the Lord their God who brought forth their
fathers out of the land of Egypt
and have taken hold upon other gods
and have worshiped them and served them therefore
has the Lord brought upon them all this evil
is it possible that this can happen to a spiritual
house as well yes oh by the way in literal
Israel did they all go apostate or were there
thousands that came out no thousands came out
all right and they joined the nazarenes yeah they
hadn't separated themselves from the Jews they
were still part and parcel of it but eventually
they were kicked out right and it came to pass at
the end of 20 years when Solomon had built the two
houses the house of the Lord and the King's house
now Hiram the king of tire had furnished Solomon
with cedar trees and fir trees and with gold
according to all his desire that then King Solomon
gave Hiram 20 cities in the land of Galilee and
Hiram came out from Tire to see the cities which
Solomon had given him and they pleased him not
there's always someone that's not pleased
right so the promises of God is not even enough
and Hiram what did he said what cities are these
which thou has given me my brother and he called
them the land of Kabul unto this day and Hiram
sent to the king's six core talents of gold
and this is the reason of the levy which King
Solomon raised for to build the house of the
Lord and his own house and Milo and the walls
of Jerusalem and Hazel and magido and Gaza
for Pharaoh king of Egypt had gone up and
taken Geza and burnt it with fire and slain the
Canaanites that dwelt in the city and had given
it for a present unto his daughter Solomon's wife
so Solomon had many problems right one of them
was women in a spiritual sense what does that mean
like communism um he thought he could reach the
world through ecumenism did he succeed no no no
not at all so Solomon built Giza and Beethoven
the Nether and balat and thought more in the
wilderness in the land and all the cities of the
store that Solomon had and cities for his chariots
and cities for his Horsemen by the way I did the
the Lord say that they shouldn't multiply horses
yes he said so right don't but
he imported them from Egypt
so was he was he inclined to rely on his own
strength oh definitely I mean even if you go
to the building of the temple there's with
certain things that weren't exactly that God
expected him to do it correct he went to the
other nations for help when God had actually
given the help to Israel right and the ones
who were the experts in the fine work were
actually descendants of the very ones which
God had blessed but had gone to the heathens
and intermarried and now came back sort of half
Associated and they did it for money yeah okay
and all the cities of the store that Solomon had
and the city or for his chariots and cities for
his Horsemen and that which Solomon desired to
build in Jerusalem and in Lebanon and all the
land of his dominion and all the people that were
left of the amorites the Hittites the parasites
the hibites the jebusites which were not of the
children of Israel the children that were left
after them in the land whom the children of Israel
also were not able utterly to destroy upon those
that Solomon Levy a tribute for Bond servers unto
this day but the children of Israel did Solomon
make no bondsman but there were Men of War and
his servants and his princes and his captains
and his rulers of Chariots and his Horsemen
there's a lot of typology in all of this right
so in other words Martin there were
things that he did that were right
and there were things that he did that were
wrong and in the beginning he was very zealous
and he was walking in the ways of David's father
except with the thing pertaining to the Chiba
but he had a inclination to be ecumenical yeah
that was a problem and so we can learn a lot
out of this and the state of the church
as it is today we have exactly the same
problems so the temple that we are supposed to
be building is also suffering the same problems
yes and it needs some kind of cleansing now
we don't have to read everything that he did
but God's people were obviously the ones
that were supposed to be the head and not
the tail let's just put that in there so when
it says the children of Israel did Solomon not
make bondsmen but there were Men of War
and his servants and his princes and his
captains and rulers of his chariots and of his
Horsemen it's talking about the army of the Lord
and we are free men that by our own
choice determined to serve the Lord
so we have to look at it in the spiritual sense
and he built all of these places and Pharaoh's
daughter came out of the city of David unto a
house which Solomon had built for her then Eddie
built Milo so he also was inclined to do things
for the other women that were in his environment
and then he made a Navy so he expanded
so the church in other words grew
and he had an association with Hiram right and
Hiram sent his Navy and they went and fetched
gold from of fear and it became exceedingly rich
and wealthy do we have a similar situation today
that the church has become rich and wealthy and
has good relations with other women definitely and
it should have actually been rich and wealthy
in the knowledge of God and proclaiming that
to the world so Martin in a spiritual sense
this Earthly thing where humans are involved
it it has good things in it and then it has things
that are not so good in it what does God really
want from his church let's look at Psalms 45 and
from verse 6. thy throw no God is forever and ever
the scepter of thy kingdom is a right scepter
that describes the government of God it's perfect
thou lovest righteousness and hatest
wickedness therefore God thy God has
anointed thee with the oil of gladness above thy
fellows all thy garment smell of myrrh aloes and
Casio who's it talking about it's talking
about Jesus yes it's the beauty of Jesus
and then look who's there King's
Daughters were amongst thy honorable women
upon thy right hand did stand the queen in Gold of
O fear who's this queen that's the church that's
the church but there are other women too that
are Honorable in other words there were many
churches not the churches of the Reformation
for example will they be represented in the
Kingdom of Heaven yes but overall an inclusive
is the bride of Christ and she is the queen in
Gold of fear she has the character so we had it
in pipe but it was tainted yeah this is perfect
how can our daughter and considering Klein thine
ear forget also thine own people and thy father's
house so shall the king greatly desire thy
Beauty for he is thy Lord and worship thou him
so there's this relationship that God wants with
his with his church and it's all about character
now this is interesting story in Kings chapter
10 when Solomon had built the house and he was
full of zeal and he hadn't done everything
right but his heart was still right later on
he became addicted to echomanism and
took all these women into his harem
we've got to watch out for that right we are
inclined to do exactly the same thing because
with that crept in all the other apostasies
yes maybe we can become the chairman of an
economical or the vice chairman of an economical
Council and think that thereby we please the Lord
we better watch out for that they better read
what happened to Solomon he became effeminate
in the end yeah but this is a beautiful Story 1
Kings 10. from verse 1 and when the Queen of Sheba
now here's one of those women that
represent more than just a woman
a church but she was a literal person but she
serves as the type of those that will stand there
one day that we just read about she heard of the
fame of Solomon concerning the name of the Lord
she came to prove him with hard questions so we've
the Church the true church has got doctrines out
there and the other churches will come with hard
questions to test us how can you say this and that
and the other hard questions must you know your
Bible how must you be prepared in here in order
to bring the message they will come with hard
questions you say this and that and the other you
talk about 1844 form it's a load of nonsense can
you show us where it says that in the Bible you
say this you say that you talk about the mortality
of man you talk about all of these things show me
and she came to Jerusalem with a very great
train with camels that bear spices and with
very much gold and precious stones when she was
come to Solomon she communed with him of all that
was in her heart she had many questions do the
people in the world have many questions Martin
how many questions do we get we've got hundreds
of them do we have people that do nothing else
than answer questions yes and they can't keep
up and they can't keep up right do you answer
questions I try but I try as well it's it's
sometimes very overwhelming let's put it that way
all right but she had questions and she
poured it out she wanted to know everything
and Solomon told her all her questions how many of
the Christians oh all of them Martin should we be
able to answer every single question where do you
get the information from to answer the question in
the Bible Spirit of Prophecy you must study the
law and the testimony okay all right so Solomon
was able to answer all the questions there was not
anything hid from the King which he told her not
who helped him must be the Holy Spirit
right okay now was that enough and when
the Queen of Sheba had seen all Solomon's
wisdom and the house that he had built
and the meat of his table now that's old English
so that should read in Modern English and the food
on his table so what did she look at she looked
at Solomon's wisdom in other words she waited up
she was like the bereans she checked whether
it was so she went and checked this is what it
says and this is how Solomon is describing him
and the house that he had built was the house
which represents the spiritual aspect the church
was it in harmony with the wisdom must have been
what about the food on this table why is that
important Martin why would she look at the food on
this table it must have been different right you
must be especially if you compare it to the rest
of the world right so the food on his table what's
what's what's all the stuff here this vegan stuff
on your table this plant-based diet why so she
looked at the food of the tire at the on the table
and she looked at the setting of his servants why
would you look at the setting at of his servants
it depends on how he was he was treating them okay
and maybe the butler at one stage sat right next
to him yeah and she thought to herself excuse me
what is the butler doing sitting next to the king
any other Earthly king would give him one smack
and put him back in his place but here this Butler
is sitting right next to the king and he's talking
with him as as though he's talking to his friend
that's weird this King was treating
people differently everybody the same
okay so the food on his table was different
should the food on outside would be different what
should people ask why is your food on
the table different should you be able
to take this book and say uh let me show
you yeah hey should we be treating people
according to their stature or according to their
relationship with Christ do they stature in
relationship with Christ okay and how that how he
sees them and the attendance of his ministers and
their apparel they were dressed differently to the
others I think the ladies were modestly dressed
and the man also were different
to the Reds and these cut bearers
everything was different she had
never seen anything like this before
and his Ascent by which he went up in unto the
house of the Lord did he go there as you know the
big knob the king of Israel or did he humbly go
up the ascent yeah and when she saw all of these
things everything was different the food on his
table was different his wisdom was unsurpassed she
checked it out it was in harmony with everything
that the prophets had said the servants were
treated different his ministers their clothing was
different his attitude was different there was no
more spirit in her no more resistance yes she
realized that his talk was the same as his walk
and a resistance crumbled and she said to the
king it was a true report that I heard in my
own land of thy acts and of thy wisdom how
be it I believed not the words until I came
and mine I has seen it how important is it
that God's children live what they believe
Act as thy wisdom you have to have the fruits of
what you say and behold the half was not told me
thy wisdomen and prosperity exceedeth the fame
which I have heard Martin if you sit down in a
Bible study they come with their hard questions
and they try and trip you up must you be fortified
you have to and you also get this at the end if
it is truly so can you compromise or must there be
fruit in harmony with what you believe it
must be so that they also can say even more
you answered all the questions and I even gained
more than I thought than I thought I would okay
so what did you say she said happy are thy
man happy are these thy servants which stand
continually before thee and that here thy wisdom
blessed be the Lord thy God which delighteth in
thee to set thee on the throne of Israel because
the Lord loved Israel forever therefore made he
the king to do judgment and Justice who's this
King actually representing Christ Christ yeah
so when the people come to a modern situation
they must say exactly the same thing they must
recognize Christ because the Lord loved Israel
he loved the church therefore he was the king
to do judgment and Justice and she gave the
king 120 talents of golden spices and great
store and precious stones there came no more
such abundance of spices as these which the
Queen of Sheba gave to King Solomon and the
Navy also of Hiram that brought gold from
her fear brought it in from of fear great
plenty of almond trees and precious stones
uh doesn't the Bible speak about living
stones doesn't the Bible speak of jewels
in the New Jerusalem and that it represents
people the 12 apostles and the Patriarchs and
all of these things so it's the building
up of the church right and almost trees
now al-makti is a very interesting Martin
because they are resistant to decay
okay they have like a natural Decay resistance and
they have a natural insecticide in them so so they
cannot be attacked they are like like pillars that
stand forever and they have a particular aroma
and what did he do with these trees that are
so enduring and then have this Aroma and are
resistant to Decay what does that tell you
about character yeah stands firm cannot be
moved cannot be moved cannot be chewed away
it it is just protected naturally protected
so the king made of the alma trees pillars for
the house of the Lord doesn't the Bible say he
who overcomes I will make a pillar in the house
of the Lord yeah the parallels are amazing amazing
that's so fascinating and for the King's house
what else did he make with the ahmud Hops also
and sultries for singers so will these pillars of
almost would make music to the Lord yeah you like
music don't You Love music you love music my wife
is a musicaholic she loves music as well they came
no such almond trees nor were seen unto this day
Martin do we have to be these trees in the end yes
we have to be almond trees in the end that we can
be called to be pillars in the house of the Lord
and King Solomon gave unto the Queen of
Sheba all her desire so it's a two-way
street she brought much into the church and she
received everything that she could ever desire
is that an explanation of what will happen yes
so what can we bring we can only bring Jesus and
the truth and the light all right but we must also
bring our efforts our best efforts and our and our
works not to attain anything but because we have
received all that we desire we have to be all in
so she got whatever she asked beside that
which Solomon gave her of his Royal Bounty
so she turned and went to her own country she and
us and our servants how much did she receive more
than she gave even more well it lets me think
of the tithing as well the Lord says prove me in
this yes you will get more out of it than you ask
for it's it's actually an amazing story and and
the typology in this is is so overwhelming now
the weight of the gold that came to Solomon in
one year was 603 score and six talents of gold but
that's a very interesting number because it's 666.
and 666 In the End can be turned round and become
a very negative thing we must be very careful
definitely if you take it in the context of you
cannot serve Mammon and God yes this has got to do
with Mammon so what we need is we need spiritual
gold yeah that cannot be turned into Mammon
besides that he had Merchant man and of the
traffic of the spice merchants and all the kings
of Arabia and all the governors of the county and
King Solomon made 200 targets of beaten gold and
600 shekels of gold went to one Target and he made
300 Shields of beaten gold and all of these things
we don't even have to read at all the fact of
the matter is eventually what happened to all
this glory and all this gold and all of these
things what happened destroyed God taken away
and instead of those beautiful Shields of
beaten gold they made Shields of brass yeah
brass for gold Martin and you shine it up so
that it looks like gold but in actual fact it's
just brass can we become brass instead of gold
unfortunately yes do you think our church could
possibly be in the business of presenting brass
for gold will have to improve right we have to go
back to the stage you will not receive the latter
rain if you have replaced the gold with brass
in fact the Bible tells us that all of King
Solomon's drinking drinking vessels were of gold
and all the vessels of the House of the forest of
Leaven and were of pure gold none where of silver
it was nothing accounted of in the days of Solomon
for the king had at Sea a Navy of tarshish with
the Navy of Hiram once in three years came the
Navy of tarshis bringing gold and silver and ivory
and apes and peacocks so King Solomon exceeded
all the kings of the Earth for riches and for
wisdom and all the Earth sought to Solomon
to hear his wisdom that's what it should be
beware of a communism loving other women
beware of exchanging gold for brass
and eventually all the ships were destroyed
yeah and there was no gold coming in anymore
and the King made silver to be in Jerusalem as
stones and Cedar made he to be as the sycamore
trees that are in the veil for abundance and
Solomon had horses brought out of Egypt and linen
yarn and the King's Merchants received the linen
yarn at a price now the Bible says he shouldn't
have brought the horses do not multiply your
horses we're supposed to rely on the Lord yeah so
we're not supposed to lie rely on our own strength
and I certainly don't want the linen of Egypt
I want a white robe of righteousness not a fake
robe like some people wear that is all white
and The Chariot came up and went out of Egypt
for 600 shekels of silver and a horse for 150
and so for all the kings of the Hittites and
the kings of Syria did they bring them out
by their means so they went over and above what
God had said so Martin we have now a picture of
what it was like in its Glory we also have a
picture of what it's like when it goes wrong
but in the end it must be like it was
when it was in harmony with God's will
right and true like this whole story
brought together the church at the end
will have to be as Solomon was in his in the
days when he was righteous yes absolutely
so when we talk about arise and shine the
canvassing work should no longer be neglected
many times I've been shown that there should be
a more general interest in our canvassing work
the circulation of our literature is one very
important means of placing before men and women
the light that the Lord has committed to his
church to be given to the world now today Martin
can the electronic World replace some of
this yeah not in an entirety because the
book is always essential but the electronic
world is important so we need to do that
the circulation of our literature can be
done electronically in the world today
and placing before men and women the light that
the Lord has committed to his church to be given
to the world the book sold by canvases open to
many Minds The unsearchable Riches of Christ in
the service of God there is work of many kinds to
be performed in the service of the temple there
were hewers of wood as well as Priests of various
orders bearing various degrees of responsibility
our church members are to arise and shine because
their light has come and the glory of the Lord is
risen upon them let those who know the truth
arouse out of sleep and make every effort to
reach the people where they are the work of the
Lord must no longer be neglected by us and made
secondary to the worldly interests we have no
time to be idle or discouraged the gospel is
to Proclaim to all the world the Publications
containing the light of present truth or to go
forth to all places is this our job 100 should
we stop infighting and concentrate on this sure
brace together why are we not more wide awake
each worker may now understand his special
work and receive strength to take hold of it
in you distinct and peculiar developments of
the boundless glory of God will bring tributary
offerings of various kinds to the feet of Jesus
every new disclosure of the savior's love turns
the balance for some soul in One Direction or the
other the end of all things is at hand the
men of the world are rushing on their ruin
their schemes their confederacies or many
new devices will continually be brought in
to make of no effect the Council of God men
are heaping up Treasures of gold and silver
to be consumed by the fires of the last days it is
essential that we involve ourselves in evangelism
by whatever means whatever means and they are so
many different ways to do it these days like you
said electronically even if you still do it
with the physical literature yes do it do it
don't neglect it but we should also start
operating institutions we're supposed to make
the health Ministry prominent we're supposed to
have schools of the prophets in other words the
schools of evangelism we should be operating on
many levels but in order to operate on many levels
we need many hands and because we know that time
is short there's no time to have lengthy study
periods that's what the spirit of Prophecy says
so we need to have concentrated short courses
Martin I think that we should do that we should
actually become involved in evangelism training
and we should have even courses of this nature
on the internet so that people can be empowered
with information to go and take the message
to the world because time is short definitely
so if we go to the Book of Mark he said
unto them go ye into all the world and
preach the gospel to every creature he that
believeth and is baptized shall be saved but
he that believeth not shall be damned how
will they believe if they haven't heard
and these signs shall follow them that believe
in my name they shall cast out Devils they shall
speak with new tongues they shall take up serpents
and if they drink any deadly thing it shall not
hurt them they shall lay hands on the sick and
they shall recover mutton we need to see this
believe it we we don't want a fake system but
we want one built on righteousness and truth if
we do what is right these promises are ours
so then after the Lord had spoken unto them
he was received up into heaven and sat on
the right hand of God and they went forth
and they preached everywhere the Lord working
with them and confirming the words with signs
following this is our job this is what we
are called to do and this is what we have
to do and the time is now the time is short and
the time is now so there's no time anymore for
Dilly dallying no time for postponing we all
have to put the shoulder to the wheel so again
let's appeal to the brethren forget the infighting
put the shoulder to the wheel let's preach the
Three Angels messages let's do it by every single
means possible let's do it by coal portering
let's do it by the electronic media let's do it by
raising up Health institutes let's do it by rising
up schools of evangelism let's do it by every
means possible amen it's time Heavenly Father
arise and shine for thy lightest calmness the
command that comes from the pen of inspiration
help us to be not only receivers in ourselves but
to be transmitters reflectors of this great light
that has been shed upon us bless your people raise
up your church and may the queens of Sheba come in
their droves receive the message everything that
is in their heart see the difference embrace the
truth and become part of the army of the Lord
as my prayer in Jesus name amen amen [Music]
thank you